i'm sick and tired of using the pixel 3
it is the best room and ni smartphone
against its taste taste strong and and this
video bieke peering the pixel 3 they the
iphone tess and shelly guys boats
strengths and weaknesses of this camera
in the lasso  tally white i de puzzle 3
is no longer living by starting off it
is porsche emotionally really like to
ogle telephoto lens crusts of the
iphone or counter the concierge especially the
much more realistic aan iphone is
specially fell counters grathem a
shallow area's
this with drinks on  several die warm
colors
computer the pixel you know
flying gray
the shows a highly when your resin
pipe file to black rose white ice is
correct
it is all the flower and as if the tap and
dep mapping to the iphone case cover can
smooth
anywhere transition into the  bad guy
get burned out and the villa noise is hugh
how can i be this mashups where a
miss nerium cheese and and in the
foreground geertsema that paul grice in
the switch arby's k  an ist xl
dispatcher charlotte shows and venus
cancellations secondary the language for the
lens
we have long compression of jury prize
in looking-glass mars the code red light
i see some more in the middle belgium it
the pixel the template and neat looks
really other s'  pose the file god the
booster shooting games to stand in the
spokes environment it seems to see the
cronshaw's summer the means the iphone
not album or with the pixel so much free
nice blue jeans no longer blue and then
the pixel values the lord is blown well again
the iphone became a like highlights
the boat havelaar the firing pepper for
the pixels word crossertje the bar a
nice the scrub in the bath times we became
how the iphones action covers at the
subject in so in door scarf with mick
sliding the pixels bikes is wt  blood is
the perfect clean white box here and is
that bird cronshaw's teething in
jeffrey captures marshall that total
folds that highlight we got this is liking
contras pixel is right yuk  how
to the white balance in your bag crashes
ambrosio decals the singles for this
image for the puzzle is a hood is
my shadow details best prices in the
crash test in the white ice and the colors
nv rico speed wheel it
your the sherry so saw the torch  and also
showcase tube porcher motibu di cui god
the pixel des have but never anything more
on the cooler side
democratic objectify what the
pixels online digital and mr
honeymoon boats those selfies
cordial white girl or contrasts viura
in the middle where the pixel is  or
crush and the detailer me here in some
other parts of the image with iphone not
all by marc hai just now this image
wi-fi and fugue fans this is drink
samsung eyes soft white and i fell the
emoji the pixels crossing the tales
and i  the hair color ene
specially the sun aan de face en de
color de face this way to cool die legal
office chair beans pixel
course a scene busing porcher fashion the
iphone is completely choo de live  feet
colors must be the contrast and cupping a
ghost recon camped skin
tones iphone that is a case that runs
next to a warm pipe the pixel is which
you could live party is born a dan a
peso in the transition between those
highlight
and the charlois is back  you and bright
and rough computer admit and demand must
national transition on iphone
moving on to another sunset scenario the
pixel is which i tardis if it the sun
coming down the weena is hot directing the
iphone god i just fry and the edging a
present the subject  is very smooth berry
no show gets the pixels scribble does already
adid sloping background in the colors
especially so off
necessary symbol light in this is
where the pixel want shines the pixel
picture let's do much better in almost
every single and me a noise levels ar
much lower in the farmer and areas which
will the gray white scarf camping the
iphone were lucky public contrast
locking living color and having more
news both
and here are extreme  me scenario before the
sun was even not to my eyes the scene was
just like what the iphone shows with the
pixels able to bring up all the sorrow's
bring already have the title make a much
greater to realistic
the technique per week in photos choose
another  relight chablis for this on what's
up the iphone die de great job capture
the dynamic range en mechanically i
just like i was in real life
met the pixel has more detailed and will
i brought up the exposure
this will be too cool
badass  and here six poster using
the display is a flash the pixel wat zoë
better more detailed and glass never and
the laszlo live show barnmans i in the
iphone is a bag let good live
what the pixel really booster up
spectators in a is kees in tasoluk
natural there  al baie des années lamina
here arrest base camp brains in a
comment section below a human dimension
to the pixel 3 so him our team that
feature
and there is the group selfie germer other
front of the device of  you have large
people the wine against sophia you can
report that is able to switch over to a
wide angle camera a tumor sap jacks
inch air frame he is fairly
discharge that way am much better
spent on additional lens at the bar
kiona you with  google software
engineer scrub download and additional
and she gets down see the dead
weather the be able to improve der kisses
pictures with all those nu and gardens and
safflower let's party imprint he want
i think we wrap the inner march wire
wheels
nex video to before  and show
the the clips and article be precise
guys say the pixel three times after
chauffeur classics the fridge for second
and also give you can i be paid to enjoy
for the french me zak and who had the job
your 227 pi and mother advice a  times
mayumi this it nips at 30 frames per sec
and dies nad pet sex animal times
with the iphone taina sorry of the char is
the exciting release paquin the pixel
two we you get in big deal
big  ed de mark have the idea who
other flush on the house so a cpu one
side of this one offers box feature you see
for gay sex that what is what thousand and
i think for ipod iphone
that is a little supplement ns what the
oil that  supplement to can listen to
this audio
this is an audio podcast on the iphone and
tnf black
this is an audio quality and the pixels
subs can see we have massive
difference encoder and contrast between
iphone tennis in the pixel 3
the pixel already is the village  intrest colors
and the photos now and then margin of video
vibration was temporary in the dynamic
range evelien week well in the mittens
stabilization
from the iphone tennis javelin looks more
stable the abdominal wall images shifting
sharding wonder how that the edge driver
percent crab stabilization down you  can
keep the thank god i feel the view you can
see hammers mother the iphone tennesse
she though i was it on and gamble
with a pixel 3 is shi xing and all the
présentes aveda
chu things arts s  ao miguel a better
cronshaw's and colors on the iphone and
feel it a dark shadow areas governments
late bloomers compression issues and
artifex one thing sancta de na
present already to the iphone
everywhere file cats that gel the iphone
xpadder and ryder cup in our none you see
all  this image
artifex en issues which doesn't make
sense week is the pixels video clip is
twice the size
nou de pixel desaever additional any
shark stabilization we dat there'll have to go and
krumping in to the image
money 5% secrecy de field and view their
friends  your work rollers and
contrast the image fluks much nicer to
the iphone you more detailed who you
can see in this still looks like it's
mother she let go for good work wishes
john green sea the highlighter much
better rich one than iphone will be blog
one  pixel
and each with shuttle john i image
stabilization it can be quiet jerry
for the iphone is nations must comparing
the screen dynamic range sunset we see
galama highly detailed  delamar shadow
the tail
wie getten sharper lukkien image na
cruiser i work for getting all the
compression artifacts moving
shifting gears
the hardware and iphone nou let's see how
how cool is this the hd edition alliance
for the 2 times
your i want i it  exposure' the shadows
the game the two of you learning objectives gillet
is building in the air no boring the
pixel grunt 10
the braille highlights is iphone
disagree job must see the sunset draw
chose look at this building see the iphone
lux norm on the the pixel
he sums garde  often slots i the whole
building can be the shaking
moving bring it's privacy where all
friezes can a shaking and moving around
this is really really wierden
i think in all three that the video that
's coming out this my heart dollar
fly  jib
[ __ ] jeffrey wat outside the night shot
not be happy mother's compression
artifacts and again that farish becomes the
video that a thai size of the iphones
and anta put a distinctio  n devil bite
for keith x the built in a really hope
that google is working on a software
update chocolate sister in law for the
sixty
the processor can handle it the sensor
can act in the file cats
competition law so our closet less money
can also choose for the  sixty she
rattled size xl 300 i am a wide
think with the pixel two we think of
kymaerica evolution ice white and
smartphone can push and trams or images
google that the great job bonner software
this is greg subscribers charmer
let's sing togethere togethere
dynamic  range get a more die tl
cans improve the edge and i think the
parent room brienne recognized a and
medicine that one that the to improve by
software is in a loop here also fell
out because shelter cat cm sangha lg apple
pear ultimate bedroom is one there images
as well paper liters margin diarrhea and
iphones en so that was used for from the
iphone en
night in google in the mean time with
religious ben focusing on july photos
htc de  lolly images like
asia is again imprint a nation of
metal tonight his motor still working
on it i think reasons gladys tender the
images was there that again arigato whisker
enough to date in focus on a
i there floyd in focus on the video side
arrow finally  wise guys my
wife for gay sex the old and the
teacher for the gave i
business let us not in religion k upgrading
and adjust focus on deny images which
she said those are great dat er zo
massimo
martha finger really get  well rounded
camera
the private sphere really great a pharmacy
a lot from the images everywhere neat the
night shot ate i the iphone is jeff no
better everywhere and a special via the
video exactly your videos and channel um
one you can briefly audio
seats and shish kebab  becomes the pixel
three house and after a king of or the
other issues like photos jumping cnc
michael persson photos i a us because
i was a 70 undefined
to a case for washing this the
massification my  for be an the pixel
make sure you we subscribe to the
channel like to have lammertink ceceba
it is and he will i think everywhere if
you get the price and the hardware and
value is yousef you are attitude becomes the
pixel
i think you is when  the wars belgian
of 2010 computer de competition make
sure you for subscribing god is to
parties and emotion then knife to advisor
videos so the max and asylum and the
right video